remake or know what parents gonna buy
their kid a dog that looks like that
creepy son of a [ __ ] when the remake
doll looks creepier than the original
doll even when the original doll had
like the [ __ ] up stitched up face I
think any kid would rather have that
doll than that doll
[Music]
child's play so child's plays a remake
of child's play you know the story the
buddy dog is possessed by a killer named
Charles Lee ray and now that doll
becomes Chucky and kills people to
slasher flick with a doll that kills
people this is a remake of that this
isn't one of those remake wolves those
in continuity reboots or anything like
that this is straight-up not even
attached to the other child's play
movies it's a tongue thing and you see
that because the premise is different
that's gonna err on the side of caution
here spoilers I don't know I'm a little
gun-shy we live in a world where I got
[ __ ] for saying Keanu Reeves was the
voice of Duke kaboom in Toy Story 4 so
don't know what the trailers have shown
or what it hasn't but this premise of
this doll is a little different as
everything is Bluetooth based so is this
new buddy doll basically Amazon echo
Amazon echo that had all of its
fail-safes removed and so Amazon echo
buddy doll Chucky starts learning and
starts killing people it's basically
iRobot but not and Mark Hamill's the
voice of Chucky this time around they
didn't want Brad Dourif again I guess
for some reason I imagine the most
logical reason it's like it's not
attached to the other child's play
movies we want to make that very clear
I'm sure there's some studio reason why
Wendy's mark hamill does a good job and
this movie does a good job at kind of
showing Chucky learn things and show why
he starts killing people hey before I
always got the feeling RIT was like I'm
a killer it's what I do this kind of
shows why Chucky starts killing people
at first is to protect the kid I like
that it gives reason to the madness also
makes Chucky kind of stalkerish and kind
of creepy because that's how stalker
creeps are no you must love me he's
gonna like that but he was born
yesterday he does look creepy though
like really he does what he smiles he's
like he kind of looks like Jack Napier
from the Burton Batman and it looks like
Joker when he's trying to make a
straight face I just want to give this
movie props for go in a new direction
granted new direction does not mean good
movie but it was a new direction I
actually felt was interesting and
generally speaking pretty well executed
halfway watching this I didn't get the
feeling it was like this was supposed to
be another thing like someone got this
script idea it was like look it's like I
Robot meets slasher flick
it's gonna be in a little kids doll if
someone was like that kind of sounds
like child's play all right well let's
just make it a new child's play kind of
felt like it went down like that
sometimes it does feel like the movie
drags on a bit and not in that jaws way
where it's like oh we're not really
seeing him it's intriguing the intrigue
comes from seeing him start to learn and
scene and start to learn that will may
be killings the way I should do it
although I felt mark hamill did a great
job with the voice I am bummed out
Chucky never did that Chucky laughs and
never happened he never really laughed
or chuckle and although the first act
dragged on though I was intrigued with
this doll and how he was learning last
act actually got pretty damn exciting
because in the end I enjoyed child's
play I thought it was a new and
interesting take on Chucky because we've
kind of moved past
magic now I guess kind of noticed that
it knows that in a lot of games where
there used to be a lot of magic and
Dragons you look at breath of the wild I
mean breath of the wild has magic and
Dragons in it but it also has machinery
mechanical monsters technology I just
notice that more and more where there
used to be all right that's a magical
story and it has dragons I might just
have technology-based monsters now
that's where we are as a society Oh
thought they did that really well in
here it's like it's a half update you
know they're updating the premise with
technology but the execution still looks
like it's old school so it looks like a
horror movie from the 80s because
they're still about a doll that kills
people but in the end I'll say child's
play was a good time no alcohol required
good thing is Amazon echo it's not a
bipedal piece of technology it becomes
self-aware I'll just be like I'll play
the Macarena a lot I'll play baby shark
that'll really get you what can it do
hey guys can [ __ ] your bank account I
don't know buy a bunch of crap on Amazon
you don't need oh wait that's just us
that's what we do right to the new
child's play have you seen it what you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and if you can
give this video a like I'd really
appreciate it this movie did come out
last weekend YouTube already buried my
Toy Story 4 spoiler talk which means
this review is really [ __ ] so we can
give it a like pass it around that would
help and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you
[Music]